جدد نائب المندوبه الى ملكيه في مجلس
الامن الدولي روبرتود دعوه الامانه العامه
للامم المتحده للتحقيق في مزاعم تسليمه
ايران طائرات مسيره هجوميه لروسيا وقال
وود خلال جلسه لمجلس الامن بشان تنفيذ
القرار الاممي المتعلق بالاتفاق النووي
الايراني قال ان عدم تحرك الامم المتحده
في هذا شان دليل على تعرضها لتهديدات
روسيه
للتهديدات الروسيه ولم تنفذ التفويض
المتعلقه بالتحقيق هو نحس باحباط لعدم
وجود اثر لهذه الانتهاكات في تقرير المجلس
بشان تنفيذ القرار
2231 والان بعد شهور من التقرير الاول
علمنا الاسبوع الماضي ان روسيا استانست
استخدامه سيارات ايرانيه من القرار
2131 ففي الرابع عشر من شهر ديسمبر الجاري
اطلق روسيا سر من المسيرات الايرانيه على
الاكياف وفي هذه التطورات الجديده يجدد
دعوتنا للامانه العامه للامم المتحده
لتوفيق وتحليل المعلومات المتعلقه بهذا
الانتهاك
من جهته قال امير سعيد ايرواني مندوب
ايران في الامم المتحده ان الطائرات
المسيره التي نقلتها بلاده الى روسيا قبل
اندلاع الحرب لا تنطبق عليها الخصائص
التقنيه المنصوص عليها في قرار مجلس الامن
الدولي رقم 2131
امبير
كما انها لمسلم للاستخدام في الصراع
الدائري في اوكرانيا
حمله التظليل
التي لا تخدم اي هدف سوى صرف الانتباه عن
شهر دول الغربيه كميات هائله من الاسلحه
المتطوره الى اوكرانيا من اجل اطاله امد
الصراع